you to want to spend chaussures pas
l'adresse vous j'ai tenté un truc dans
l'intro oui je sais aujourd'hui sur
parasite un jeu indé qui est censé faire
peur alors je pense qu'on peut interagir
en faisant un clic gauche oui comme dans
tous les jeux c'est entièrement logique
qu'est ce qui les rend sa main droite
est ce que c'est un une craie oui ça a
l'air de trine crée alors on va faire
des cris partout des croix partout pour
indiquer notre chemin vers ce qui est
cool c'est que c'est pas trop glauque
cet endroit il ya des partis tous les
soirs je les fait tous les soirs à fond
on s'aime c'est carrément glauque et tu
sais que ça est tracté july de hockey
donc il a attiré par la lumière mais là
il ya d'autres lumières
parce que normalement je crois qu'on
peut voilà là j'ai éteint ma lampe
ce qui est génial j'aurais voulu
traverser à la nage
ça aurait été mieux bon alors faire des
croix savoie on n'est pas trop grillé je
pense que s'ils passent par là il est
pas au courant que nous on est passé par
là juste avant non non non ah ouais ok
alors droite devant gauche je dis j'en
fais une croix comme des vieux mecs on
va dire tout droit au but et on fait je
crois pour te connais tout droit y avait
pas un âge j'ai cru voir un sale truc
là-bas au fond monde on va dire tout
droit encore atteint mais ça fait
carrément peur ja un moment va tomber
sur un espèce de monstre qui aura capté
deux jambes et qui fera coucou tu veux
voir ma [ __ ] et je pense qu'à ce moment
là
ofra bois les voilà un bon jusque là
c'est un petit peu en fait sa une chose
qu'ils aiment c'est peu
il m'a fait peur l'enfoiré oui on s'est
fait attaquer par une espèce d'araignées
géantes c'est exactement ça [ __ ] what
the fuck
c'est quoi ce monstre le monde se
plurent claqué de tous les jeux
d'horreur comme dans mon jeu d'horreur
je vais mettre une araignée qui
attaquent le joueur parce que oui les
araignées ça fait peur jusqu'au très
convaincant de quelqu'un qui fait des
études de commerce elle bon alors le
coup décret et je peux faire de créer
voilà ok on va étendre notre langue
comme ça mais fait ne croit bordel de
merde voilà ta j'ai peur de tomber sur
cette [ __ ] d'araignée géante la a fait
remarquer qu'elle est attirée par la
lumière du coup j'étais à ma lampe savez
quoi on va rester appuyé voilà nous ont
fait pas des on laisse pas des miettes
quand on fait tout le trajet bonjour au
revoir
ils étaient juste là où j'ai vu juste là
j'ai vu moi je les veux et je n'ai pas
trop aimé d'araignée complètement
horrible astro des ovocytes passée par
là alors bon en fait la crise
accouchement rien finalement art je vois
de la lumière
est-ce que je vais pouvoir m'inscrire
est ce que c'est que ça evin [ __ ] de
rap artères watts aurait fait une croix
dessus au nom
il s'est suicidé une minute de silence
la main sur le coeur pour sera
abominable qui pue et la mort non mais
c'est réussi mais c'est quoi ce g22 what
the fuck ou là ou là au fond il y avait
j'ai cru voir des petits yeux blancs là
bas ou si koussa l'araignée
bon je vais laisser un peu lumière parce
que sinon vous allez vous allez juste
pas rien avoir en fait je crois qu'il
était vers là-bas et je crois que je
vais vers là-bas ça ça fait un espèce da
de toiles d'araignées c'est [ __ ] de
trait sur les murs on se doit être fait
exprès l'auteur s'est dit on va faire un
but au dernier sous les murs pour plus
de diversion dans dans ce jeu un art ce
n'était pas le bon chemin
dès qu'il ya un impact de balle sur
chaque carreau en plus avaient hier en
bois qui passait par là et café
oui j'ai mis très très bien rambo parce
que j'ai pris v1 des cours de génocide
quand j'étais petit à on est déjà passé
par ok on peut faire une marelle mais
oui mais bien la petite araignée allez
je décide une petite mare elle voilà
c'est parti et à cette espèce de brut
chasse d'eau en fonte latin est horrible
abominable il nous faut une ambiance
sonore téléphone pour notre jeu et
est-ce qu'on peut un jour éventuellement
s'amuser sur ce je déteste cette piscine
toxiques parce que dedans il ya plein
d'hommes a régné comme c'était quoi ce
[ __ ] de bruit de merde c'était quoi ce
[ __ ] de bruit gérald sgobbo fred un
levier
j'adore j'adore quand tu actives un
levier à peut-être là n'ont pas non
c'est cool on a activé un levier qui a
activé quelque chose au pif sur cette
map
bonjour au [ __ ] mais ça aurait été
beaucoup plus drôle de faire une marelle
est ce que ces 106 de te faire peur ça
c'est fait ah ah bah voilà
[ __ ] mais regardez quoi mais qu'on me
l'a même pas de [ __ ] d'animation
qu'est ce que c'est que ça le jeu se
frise shoji de relancer dès lors j'ai
pas envie là voilà c'est une vidéo cours
certain temps je pense que plus
longtemps sur ce jeu ça ne vous amuserez
vraiment pas un
de quoi tu es sur une mariée tous
ensemble aller est avec toi tu te
réveilles pas je t'éclate se moqua sur
ta gueule
alors maintenant il faut faire ça